you guys we are here for you we are your
queen sluggies and we are here to tell
you that you may have missed the live
stream you may feel like oh my God I
missed the slumber party but we have
good news for you you have two days left
to watch the video on demand and you can
see all the stuff that you miss we wish
you were there and you were there in
spirit now pay out [ __ ] and come join
us
you can go to moment.com trash Tuesday
you missed out
but you can be there in spirit if you
just cough up a few bucks
this bacon you may know her from I don't
feel like I have to introduce the guest
Carlos did you guys not see smile yeah
did you guys have the number one hit
movie of all time I can't believe it
says Wawa yeah I got it made oh and you
were on um maravista yeah and my dad's
from Philly oh
um this was made by Taylor bling okay
check this [ __ ] out I'm assuming it's a
girl honestly it could be the boy Taylor
be Taylor Hanson who knows I want to get
one you got to get one what could mine
say
um yours could say stupid smile scary
smile
Kevin Bacon's daughter yeah you're a
Cedric's daughter can you can that
should be nepo baby apparently that's
what people call them yeah I've been
seeing that all over tick tock not
really but there are nepo babies
I mean there are mildly nepo babies and
they're real nepo babies and you are my
mild you are the mildest nepo baby no
you're just talented because here's the
thing nepotism is annoying if someone's
not talented and they're getting stuff
you smashed
did you see it I know everyone in my
family has seen that she is that's her
saying no we're used to it honestly I
call my mom right now
I want you to tell us what what happens
we'll bleep out there yeah what happens
in the movie what happens yeah so she's
lying oh my God if you haven't seen it
Delilah it's okay she doesn't care oh
you guys I'm watching it with jeans
tonight
first of all I I am thank you for going
to see it I don't even care if you I
know I know you don't I know also oh
Botox is looking good [ __ ]
did you see how amazing wrinkly wrinkle
my head but if you weren't wrinkly and
like you weren't wrinkly like wrinkly
you were like emaciated you were scared
and my mom goes to me after seeing it
really not fun seeing your daughter
decompose right before
I was like okay decompose that's a
strong word choice were they so proud of
you though you [ __ ] yeah they were so
good they were stoked it was cool
I can't I don't want to spoil anything
you can spoil now I know that there's a
I know my mom was talking about a car
scene
by the way the fact that your mom will
lie for you that's what we learned no
this is actually that's what we learned
so this is actually fun because you
haven't seen it yeah this is fun this is
fun no don't care about me you're like
this is so fun to be here you don't give
a [ __ ] about my career and he's no
okay Sophie and I share an obsession
with the challenge oh right right I do
know this about Sophie yes yes and I'm I
yeah she gave me the biggest gift anyone
ever has given me which is that I was
washing dishes and I was having a really
annoying night you can skeet not wash a
dish he washes them back
oh I can start saying we kind of do half
and half and this half it was I'm me
doing it okay I was doing dishes I was
having an annoying night and I get a
FaceTime from Annie and I'm like oh my
God why is she FaceTiming me that's so
cool and I answer and she's with [ __ ]
Nehemiah who's a member of the cast of
do you watch it I watch so I know the
classics here we go
[Music]
thank you to our sponsor rocket money
cancel unnecessary subscriptions with
rocket money today go to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday seriously it could save
you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday the holidays came early
this year ladies and if you're still not
sure what to get the man in your life
then look no further than our friends at
manscaped get free shipping and 20 off
by going to manscape.com and using trash
Tuesday at checkout that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com and use
code trash Tuesday get your Mana gift
you'll both enjoy the gift of manscaped
his jingle balls will thank you hi slugs
I'm so excited my tour is like literally
less than a week away whoa and we just
added a second show in San Francisco yes
Carlos you heard that right
um so I'm San Francisco Portland Seattle
Phoenix you can get tickets at Esther
onice.com and check out my new solo
Audio Only pod cast my pleasure
available wherever you listen to your
audio podcasts
I will see you in the very beginning of
December December 1st and December 2nd
and 3rd in Michigan I will be New Year's
I will be in Las Vegas at Wise Guys
December 30th and 31st I'm being gonna
be at Flappers in Burbank for one show
January 7th I'm going to be in Wisconsin
in January in February I'm going to be
in Florida and in March I'm going to be
in Florida I'm going to be in Canada in
April go to annieleterman.com shows also
you guys my solo podcast Annie wood is
here I'm having so much fun it's so
amazing it's coming straight from my
heart you can watch it every Tuesday
after this show after trash Tuesday at
noon I'm trying my best to get there and
chat live with you guys each week it's
just been so incredible please check
that out on youtube.com Annie Letterman
can we please go on the challenge no I
think we can well I think we can I'll I
need to get in better shape even though
I really need to get in better shape I
need to get you're good no no no I'm not
good you're good I'm not good my hands
sweat anything climbing
but that's good high pressure comes you
don't want to be perfect therapist says
no more competition for the rest of your
life oh in terms of physical competition
because of my head swimming you can host
the the um would you say you're like a
naturally competitive person
um I think I was forced to be
competitive and I don't want to be yeah
it makes me like sweat even thinking
about you don't seem like I know not at
all no no not competitive
like uh not competitive like career-wise
or stuff like that you were forced
Sports yeah sports stuff then I go nuts
right like I will cuss my entire do you
think that's natural or do you think
that's from like the pressure when you
were a kid it's pressure I don't like it
being in the losing team yeah if I'm
gonna be in a team you were like racist
look up spoiled Sport and you don't want
to be a spoiled sport no I don't and
that's the thing it's like you're gonna
see people are like let's be on kalila's
team don't be on my team because I
expect Excellence oh yeah
I actually think she would like to be so
like mean to her partner would be great
yeah and the guys really crying and she
would she'd make like CT cry that'd be
so good no but the thing is she would
also be the one that worked the hardest
and then and then [ __ ] um Johnny
Bananas would take the money
you know I have a break also so nice and
I have a side frame picture of the
moment he took that no I know you told
me did he take the money from who's he
took the money from what sir I don't
remember her name uh Sarah Sarah sorry
Sarah I have I'm not competitive at all
and in fact when people want to play
games I'm like okay I'm gonna go for a
walk I hate games do you mean like
emotional games like you're like don't
play Quit Playing Games With My Heart
Like A Backstreet yeah what kind of
games like board games sports games
tennis chess like you know what I mean
I'm just like I'm good what happens what
do you think the outcome is going to be
I don't like to do things if I'm not
good at them right like because I it's
like I hate to fail it's not just fun to
me like it's like I feel like I look
stupid shame yeah shame it's called um
shame yeah that's what the S is
understand exactly that's what it stands
for big shame girl
um but the kids scoots kids are obsessed
with games so they always want to play
and I'm like all I have to do some work
I'll be over here I'll be the the uh
referee yeah now okay wait no you would
smash the challenge I always look at
life as like you have choices on how to
work with people you can either be this
is so annoying sorry
um you can sorry
um you can either be like a CT or you
can be a Johnny Bananas and Wes is a
side note I'll talk about in a second I
realize what Wes is
um okay so CT is when he has a partner
and he's like in the final challenge
um he is very encouraging because you're
the best runner in the world you're an
amazing Runner you're the number one
Runner and these [ __ ] like literally
become yes yeah that would be a good
partner for me which is incredible right
it's like we all can dream of a CT he's
lying you'll see in the like and the the
testimonials he'll be like she's not a
good one I know I know like he'll sell
you out man but you cannot believe it
yeah in the moment it's really all that
matters and then Johnny Bananas will
literally drag your arm out of the
socket and be like yes run [ __ ] yeah
like he'll just like he doesn't care
like he's like tough love but it's
actually just tough right but you'll win
but either way you'll win with these two
now Wes Wes's issue is Wes is a
mastermind but ever nobody trusts him so
nobody listens to him but if they listen
to him they would win but no one wants
to listen but also no one listens and
then he gets really like on no one's
listening yeah he's a ninja he's like a
Stompy like grumpy he's grumpy about it
what is it about him that people don't
want to listen to if they know how to
they already know he's masterminding
like it's so Mastermind but also but
also he has this way of being like okay
this is what we need to do and like he
acts so confident about it but it's like
West so I don't know how to explain it
everyone's like nah come on I don't know
why like because they know it's coming
they know he's like he's like pulling
some manipulative moves and stuff yeah
and it's for his his win and yeah I
thought maybe it was like his voice
because there are some registers that I
just they could be talking straight into
my face or snapping their fingers in
front of me and like whatever they're
saying doesn't land like it's like a
mismatch of like voice what is that kind
of like a husky voice like a no like you
kind of like sounds like smoker like
sometimes not no shade but like George
has to repeat things to me six times oh
you look like this a little work for you
I sound I I sounded like
I sounded like you for like a week
because I was
um like had congestion in my chest I
loved it yeah I'm so upset it's a power
move I love it no pneumonia pneumonia
voice is the way to go you need to have
like a right yeah like polio throw wait
wait
can I find it is that annoying yeah it
is you have a little bit of a deep voice
to begin with I have a very resonant
voice voice that's why I was gonna say I
am talking quiet now but like my friend
Michael's always like your voice always
pierces through the room you do my Ras
yeah come out everyone would be talking
in the Halls they've come to me and be
like everyone's [ __ ] each other but
you're the only one wait Susie aren't we
aren't we voice twins is what is that
what they say that's what people say oh
they can't hear the difference that's
what the people say really I can't hear
it either I say something
I love you I love you
oh it is similar is it really maybe I I
can't personally hear it but I guess how
you hear yourself is not how you sound
to others can I say something yes you
can can I say something and this is
maybe very rude but I feel like it's
kind of obvious so she sounds like loved
by two living parents
have a twang of pain yeah belonging of
Desire I don't have a twang of pain I
think no no you I have a I have a twang
of pain no you're a little Annoying a
hollow man
I think mine is more like a nasal
collapse no hers was gone your dad was
just not present
I didn't talk in this part sorry I found
the time sorry she's picking up a face
forget it [ __ ] forget it we can we
you guys you guys I've been like foaming
at the mouth wanting to talk about this
for months but I feel like we have held
back Annie and I but I really want to
talk about Ezra Miller I know everyone's
like tiptoeing about it yeah but I think
it's like can we finally just can
someone talk about it tell me what
happened okay
do we can Carlos can we pull up like
these specifics I'll give you the also
how annoying is it that he is or that
that they are they and this is going to
be the most difficult this is gonna be
the most difficult thing I've ever
talked about just because
wait can I just say one thing Carlos
texted me he's like I'll be outside in a
hat and a shirt and I was like I know
what you look like
don't worry what other descriptors did
you get that blue shirt blue shirt
that's a little too thirteen also you
know I used to live on this block you
used to live on this block on this block
I remember I went there oh yeah you did
going to your house party yeah you have
House Parties it was that was the last
one I had this was like eight years ago
yeah I'll go to a Premiere I'll go to
house Parts anything with you oh you
should come with me
I was just there with my friend all
night I are you the same as me yes I'm a
hospital friend I'm like Cedars 4 AM
wait one thing I was at Cedars at 4am
you know how it gets so yeah during the
day too Cedars is wild wild and so it
was just her and I and all the junkies
of course and like after a while my
friend that was there was like so see
um why is it she's British she's like
why is it that the junkies are only
talking to you and I was like you're
right and she's like all of them have
come up and said like when are you
leaving and if you have a cigarette and
I was like what the [ __ ] is that maybe
they saw the movie no maybe I just think
I give off junkie Vibes or something
well you are decomposing in front of us
it's just such a good choice it's like
you're rotting
that's so good it's so dramatic yeah
okay Ezra is that a um spoiler no no
it's just her mom being mean to her yeah
but in a supportive supportively made
okay so the short of it is Ezra Miller
is um
perks of the Wallflower yes boy read the
book loved him milky boy but clearly
suffers from some form of mental illness
um goes to Hawaii has a lot of um police
reports and gets arrested several times
there now to me it's manic it seems yes
before all of this like I did not know
Ezra Miller by name
um I gave and okay so we have to go
years ago I told Annie like I was like
hey like a friend of mine is you know
dating so and so and he is absolutely
batshit crazy this is before anything
way before all of this and it was yeah
but this is before anyone knew it ever
like he ever got arrested and well you
can you can so then okay so then
there's a mutual friend right there's a
mutual friend of ours who who tells us a
story about her relationship with Ezra
Miller Okay and like wasn't it like he
was painting her toenails it was like
weird things I think he would like he
like worshiped her feet there was like
weird things happening well I think he
like like rushed like they were she took
him to church because I was like okay
bad move she goes to church wait she
took him to church right also I wouldn't
be like oh oh my gosh yay
um thank you Carlos I wouldn't be like
you know what let's go to my like
religious that's just odd I've gone on a
date to church yeah but just to be silly
right like not to be
seriously mom Quaker are you Quaker well
yeah because my dad's from Philly my
dad's quicker oh my God
the degrees that I am close to making no
it's like we're so I always have been
like I didn't even know yeah you didn't
even know your whole life walking around
do you want to go to work yeah I would
love to be with you that's the one that
I really really actually think is like
they can invite um Audis of course no
Everyone's an Audi I told you yeah in my
quicker meeting there was a guy in a
yamaka with one of the Jewish yeah no
it's just whoever wants it'll go because
I like to I you know surprisingly I like
to go to mass I like to go to I like
going to church like spiritual Gathering
oh it's amazing I love it it's almost
like watching people in their safe
meditative space feeling like Pious is
something that I like to see people
kneeling on the pews it like it brings
me warmth do you know what happens in a
Quaker Meeting I don't okay it's quiet
until if like basically oh wait hang on
Annie did teach me this when you're
moved to speak yeah yeah yes and I
really hope that you are because you've
always moved to speak I've literally
never I mean I've me too though I've
since I was a kid I started every
meeting
like I speak too much but I'm
embarrassed but you're not embarrassed
so you're like I know it's like I know I
can't wait God is moving through me a
lot wait that is the kind of similar to
like AAA because I know that Bobby is
always like there's just some people in
it AAA who treat it like their stage
time where it's like they just yes no
Bobby doesn't get to pretend like he's
not one of those people and Bobby
doesn't get to separate I know what I'm
saying though those attention seek
because I've gone with friends and stuff
before and like those people that are
like this is my stage and then they
always go on so long and they are I
they're hitting their beads so much how
about the people outside of AAA that you
meet and talk and then you like you go
oh you're sober and then they start
hitting their story beats and I'm like
there was this guy I was with recently
and I just it's like practice I had
already met him so I had already heard
his like I already knew I was like I
yeah you talk okay but he like doesn't
there's no yeah I don't like him you
like when people think like their
stories are planned because they've said
them so many times then I'm like okay
I'm listening to a monologue yeah let me
see your nails and I'm like I had good
like we're not having a back and forth
you know but I'm like I have really good
stories like I almost lost a nipple you
don't want to hear my stories like it's
like he had no interest aren't these
cool they're so cool and there's so much
on them I know okay so what did Ezra do
so basically
um my friend took him to church and at
church
um he felt moved to speak at her church
but it wasn't basically was like God is
an Abomination and like he's not wrong
but like he he basically humiliated her
in front of her entire congregation good
message wrong delivery wrong place we
also just let people like let people you
know because it's just not your time to
be like hating on it yeah no it's not
but this is before so Andy and I we've
just been sending each other Ezra Miller
for like the last three years I've just
been like oh here he is again
and this last one sent me she was like
oh he might be facing 26 years he's
there's no way there's no way what's
that little rascal up to this he's just
like throwing chairs at people's heads
and stuff like doing like a salty it's
like sad he's probably he obviously has
a serious like mental illness he does
yeah and I think mad and not for the
last one was for like theft and like
burglary which is like a felon right oh
I feel bad for him but does our friend
still get to brag about hooking up with
him anymore I don't think so I think
once someone spirals this hard like you
almost never want to tell anyone she
told me this right and by the way I'm
not knocking bragging I love name
dropping I mean I see one million times
you're welcome I'm so happy like you
like being in this movie has really like
given me a lot to brag about I'm like
yeah I'm like I know her but you still
won't post one Instagram
okay let's take another one should we
just blur our faces out no I think today
I could do better I was just so tired I
was like it was Wild by the way everyone
yeah everyone keeps commenting I look
like Jim Carrey so you're not the only
one it was it was like that's after
Annie talked about it oh got it yeah is
it yeah no what's this what's the
difference
it's all of it oh yeah but we were
watching um Hollow Man the other day
Okay and um you you went back and
watched that movie Just I walked in
hotded it on Todd had it on Todd knows
whatever I'm just like what no we were
watching we watched the fly I thought
your dad was in the fly for like 20
minutes and then I realized we're
watching Hollow Man
um I was like holy [ __ ] but your dad
looks like heaven bacon too as well he
looks like I mean I mean he looks no he
doesn't look like Kevin Bacon he looks
like um he looks like Jim Carrey okay so
then it's all of us you're just and dude
look Carlos look up Kevin Bacon young
and you guys will be like that's the
same person yeah did we already do that
no no okay it's wild how it looks like
just me wait go down let me find it I
mean that's so cute look at seven
Tremors how's my life that is me is that
not me like we are identical who is this
don't stare at him like that [ __ ]
he was already with your mom then
probably right I mean it's for a movie
or something I think I know I'm not okay
okay so not cool
did your parents ever play a couple in a
movie that's when they they did a movie
together that's how they met what movie
was that it was it was like a play that
they made into a movie it wasn't like a
big movie
no one saw it I think it's called lemon
I don't know I don't remember oh that's
so disgusting actually what that I don't
remember
what's it called lemon sky and I think
my dad was gay in it or something look
at that cute look at my mom in my real
life always falling for gay guys wait is
that what happens to you I was just
talking to a friend about that well
Annie has you know suspected are you
don't fall in love with gay guys I can
tell with gay guys I fall in love with a
lot I've dated you guys for a year
I fall in love with like guys who have
either had sexual experiences with men
or still find men attractive which I'm
not really okay with we know it's worse
yeah what is it the shoulders I think I
have the shoulders too no you don't no a
little bit we've been through this you
don't okay you don't know how the
shoulders are we have a refrigerator
situation wait I went on a date with a
girl how was it you did and it turns out
I I recently yeah like last Saturday was
it like an internet it was like a a kind
of a boat was it a zoom date no no no it
well I don't want to like because there
are lesbian network no it was um it was
on hinge but I set my Prof my settings
to just girls because I was like wait a
second like I want to see truly like
where I stand I actually call it
unhinged
it's exactly where what my mindset was
and I just never go out on dates like
even when I was single younger dating
like one-on-one has never been myself
it's awkward there's too much like yeah
sure yeah hi what do you do and then
you're waiting for the next what
question am I gonna ask next what else
do I have left it's horrible so usually
it's always like my friends and I are
here I hang out if you want to hang out
like that's usually yeah I can observe
them right in in the wild and without
the pressure of like
um but this time I was like oh let's do
something different let's shake it up
let's go fully with a girl I'm sure it's
much easier to go on a date because it's
like not you know what I mean it's fun
and I think I am attracted to women like
sexual is she gonna rape me yeah exactly
you're not like actually you're scared
yeah I know it's so true I have to kiss
her at the end I don't have the
excitement of getting [ __ ] oh my God
bashed over the head with a [ __ ] yeah
caveman stick what are they what are
those things called but that's exactly
it there's like a feeling of safety and
ease yeah which is not as hot right but
then I that's cereal I might I can wear
my heels and not worry about having to
twist my ankle when I'm running yeah I
wasn't terrified to turn my back for
once yeah for once I wasn't terrible dry
as a bone weren't you really pretty yeah
super hot like so lovely did she give
you panty Splash no the Cube's got
dandruff girl she's got dried up that
[ __ ] scalp all right I could maybe I
think no what I liked about her is that
we were able to kind of just like get to
I was just like I don't want anything
like long term she's like neither do I
and she's like liar yeah yeah you said
it first so what was she gonna say like
well I do unless you change your mind no
but I think we were kind of like we'll
probably be pretty good friends what did
she drive to the exactly friends but you
didn't get the panty Splash but I love
that joke by the way it's one of my
faves would it uh what does a lesbian
bring to a first date
wait so so no panty Splash you're just
gonna be friends
right so there was maybe half a penny
but then you had to be friends if you go
on a lesbian date do you have any
friends out yeah I think but it's kind
of a win-win because like she's
legitimately someone I had a good time
with like right oh [ __ ] but if you go on
a date with a guy and it doesn't work
out it's hardly you can't really be
friends it's hard for me to try yeah
right you can no if I've dated them for
like a period of time then we can be
friends after but it's a guy like one
date no way I feel like you can pull off
one day guy friends I would always just
like get black out and then like hook up
with that yes I know that's why I quit
drinking because I literally was like
annoy you can't keep doing that yes and
it would be like the first like hour of
the day I'd be like this sucks I don't
like you at all I'm not attracted to you
and then I'd be like let me just [ __ ]
yeah I'm just going like no yeah exactly
like why oh it's so sad like kalila will
tell me a story she'll be like yeah I
just you know I told them I wasn't
feeling anything like you just don't
like when you were feeling it you can't
do that no I can't no I have sex with
them I date them for three years yeah
not exactly not like anymore obviously
but like when I was younger I there was
no option of like maybe you just don't
want to it was always like how how drunk
do I have to get to [ __ ] this one yeah
paying 12.99 for every month was it for
like three years no it was an insect
identifier oh I have like these ones
that they're like camera filters that
I've been paying like 90 no that's the
insect finder it just turns on FaceTime
Zoo because it's yeah
are you guys wasting money on
subscriptions yes 80 of people have
subscriptions they forgot about maybe
for you it's an unused Amazon Prime
account or a Hulu account that never
gets streamed there's this great app
that we all use that helps us track all
of our expenses and because of it we no
longer waste money on subscriptions we
don't use you will be shocked you might
have heard of it it's called Rocket
money formerly known as true bill the
app shows all your subscriptions in one
place and cancels what you don't want
for you rocket mini can even find
subscriptions that you didn't know you
were paying for you may even find out if
you've been double charged for a
subscription to cancel a subscription
all you have to do is press cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest get
rid of useless subscriptions with rocket
money now go to rocketmoney.com trash
Tuesday seriously it could save you
hundreds per year that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday definitely worth checking
out look
we've got a lot to deal with over the
holidays okay we got to deal with
all the food the presents all the stuff
I don't need to be Hocking up hairballs
from blowing you okay how about this
how about when the only blowing we're
worrying about is the snow blowing okay
I don't want to worry about dealing with
coughing up Hocking up long curly hairs
all right trim your nards and ladies
make it so they can't not do it give it
to them as a present and then go oh my
god did you try the present did you try
the present did you oh my God the
present the present let's see it I can't
wait and it can be a fun game and
Annie's right I'm tired of finding
Santa's beard down here
down my dude's pants but also this it's
like I don't really care if there's hair
there but like show me that there's some
type of consideration and Care by
trimming it yes leave a soul patch all
right
um not the whole thing listen it's fun
you can put have a carve your initials
in there okay so they don't cheat on you
get creative
inside the performance package 4.0
you'll find the signature lawnmower 4.0
this electric trimmer has proprietary
Advanced Skin safe technology candy cane
balls are no more what are candy cane
balls also this really reduces the risk
of ingrown hairs ingrown hairs are my
nightmare I hate them but I do kind of
like popping them a little bit I do
and it reduces the risk of grooming
incidents get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code trash Tuesday at
manscape.com every guy has manscaped on
their wish list get him products he'll
actually use this holiday season that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code trash Tuesday
get your man a gift you'll both enjoy
the gift of manscaped his jingle balls
will thank you
listen
it's a great stocking stuffer if you
want to stuff stuff her stocking
I gotta write these things I would like
to know what it's like for five minutes
to not be to walk around feeling like
not everybody could just kill me yeah
you know what I mean like I walk around
and I'm like everyone could probably
kill me oh I'm sorry you're turning our
pockets into a woke uh I know I'm sorry
liberal agenda liberal agenda I'm sorry
I I have to tell you guys literally I
might as well just get vaccinated again
just get a booster in front of us I
haven't gotten like had 12. no I haven't
I just have abortions are boosters we're
disgusting [ __ ] [ __ ] right we're the
DNC after I got it I stop getting them
the vaccines are her did you guys get
the new one did you get the new one no
guys come on I know after I got covered
I'm a republican at this point let's be
friends
it's a liberal hoax so wet but when I
was on Kelly I read her and Josh Gmail's
tarot cards it was so fun yeah why don't
you read ours I can read them yeah of
course wait that's amazing I would like
to go to the car what we do want you to
do that but also do you want to show us
the gift bag oh you guys do an unboxing
how Charles Josh Jamal tall tall Josh
tall someone else do the unboxing Bobby
if you tell Bobby that what am I doing
then he will she's the greatest person I
met her do you want can I tell you my
feed and Kelly Clarkson story that was a
farm I swear I didn't fart no she won't
know I didn't like present myself how I
usually do when I'm Starstruck which is
like I'm Annie Letterman my name is on
The Comedy Store thing I know Joe Rogan
I didn't do it I know soci bacon
my number one best friend ever
it'd be like who's that no okay here we
go we got this amazing so important so
cute it doesn't fit in my car thing
though I know why I know come on oh this
one's good though but it will only go
down to the handle yeah I know it's like
do you think they could make the I have
a feeling you drive like I drive too
whip a turn and then the drink flies
well I think that the cups are just not
Universal sizes they vary from car to
car right uh yeah yeah so relax I think
if you had a bigger wine chips what are
wine chips Hawaiian Hawaiian both of us
were such idiots
red sea salt so I like the hat but it
does potato chips very round on the top
you do know that right yeah potato chips
it's probably four wines it makes very
little head oh I which I which I want
because I have a very big you want to
say it look like a yamaka on me well
this is can I tell you are you afraid of
what it looks like underneath this is
kind of sick a Madonna record oh wait it
does fit I love that looks really good
Madonna
I've been following on Instagram and
really enjoying her weird
um 70 year old flexes
seven-year-old labia [ __ ] is so funny
why who likes who likes red wine I'll
take the wine you yeah I can't drink
I'll be back
yeah
I'm sober from alcohol but I will tell
you he's like no no it's okay and you're
like no no you have to you have to [ __ ]
me what I give I'd be getting rejected
physically by Carlos what I would give
for Annie to be the first person to [ __ ]
Carlos I never my entire my end female
first female female okay I love this bag
too can I try your hat yeah I have a
tiny head though it's Teddy fresh it's
by Gila Klein I have such a small head
oh
oh that actually looks so cute on I knew
it oh I love these kind of hats I have a
huge face and a huge head so the big the
bigger the Hat The more I've never had
Comfort I feel
in my life do you guys think dini baby
saw smile and like regrets it you know
what here's what I'll say about dini
babies I don't like the Der oh remember
the one I dm'd oh yes yeah oh I'm so
glad that that's what you meant okay
um but he's going strong with Kayla but
I can't no I mean it's fine I'm going
I'm good I'm just I'm just wondering
this is so sad uh here's the win for you
I don't really saw you on date night
dude maybe you should scoot along
obviously no scoot is so Superior to
Genie babies I'm sorry food is King I
know this King the way he ignores you I
know it is when you remember sending me
that picture we ran into we ran it into
um each other at the we doubled it it
was an impromptu double date and like I
was obviously being crazy like it was
like
you know how he does just ignores me and
then and and then when we got home I
sent her a picture because I was talking
and he just fell asleep on the couch I
was like wow talk so much he just passed
out like mid conversation oh I don't my
I I just my friends in town and she came
over to go on a walk this morning and
she goes I just want to be quiet like
Todd's sleeping I'm like Todd does not
have any expectations of not being
completely woken up at all yeah he is
like able to shut off my I feel like we
need that though like the balancing one
because we're some time when you called
me at like 1am and you just passed the
phone yeah and I thought he was so sweet
he was like you know I think that she's
just having a hard day and I could hear
you like mumbling in the background and
you're like tell scoot what I need
I was like I think that you know if you
have like confidence
I didn't say the Klonopin I was like
maybe something a little bit mild there
Kelly Kelly thank you Kelly you're the
best so there's better than you can
imagine no and I just saw scoot on in
the um Mila Kunis movie oh yeah and I
was like scoot is so hot dude okayness
in the scoot movie that's what that is
you're right he says that he doesn't
think he's hot he is so he's always like
I'm not sexy and I'm like oh my God
scoot like you're dumb oh like he's such
a sexy Dad such a sexy daddy
good
I know they get mad they're like you
dumb [ __ ] wait I actually I had the I
saw the best comment of my life okay
it was I was from Andrew Santino's
podcast someone said
I used to like Annie but then she wore
those glasses and now I think she's a
piece of [ __ ] how funny is that to not
think I'm funny because I'm wearing
glasses
and like just like you can oh I saw a
good comments
Talk Amongst herself what was the name
of your cat in the movie mustache
mustache I went I did Colbert and on the
YouTube Someone commented
like most of them were nice and then
someone commented
oh she's addicted to Vicodin so sad
happened to my uncle
is there Uncle Jim Carrey because I
could see the resemblance
so like Why That's So Random no I hate
when they make stuff like that's where I
really want to respond oh one thing I
got I just got in a fight with a with a
fan that was being annoying and I feel
bad and then they sent me an Erawan gift
card to my agent which is so funny I'm
like oh you you are a fan they were like
giving me this lecture but I shouldn't
wear my purse on stage and to stop
wearing my purse because it makes them
feel uncomfortable I'm like I spend
extra two hours after every show meeting
everyone signing their [ __ ] for free
doing all this stuff I make you feel
uncomfortable like I'm not sticking
around also I wear my purse because I
have 80d I've taken my purse off twice
since I bought it I leave it at this
restaurant I have this I have wounds on
my shoulder from wearing the purse no
yeah it's not good for me everything I
lose it I have to keep it on you
scumbags why do you think the worst
about them it's I've realized that my
purse is almost like a security blanket
because when I'm out with people like I
don't like I'm not completely
comfortable with sifting through my
purse is like a way for me to like kill
time and rest to kind of like reset oh
I'm just looking for something
all the time I have really really I'm
maybe my ADD is not at the level of some
like people or like Annie yeah what me
no yeah it can really really get in the
way I have really bad like short-term
everything got it
um and so I yeah does it like bother you
guys when because I don't I lose
everything but I don't care I'm like
this to be expected yeah but I used to
really like I would that's Tyler Jordan
myself but scoot like he really doesn't
like it when I lose things because his
ADHD is way worse than oh wow ours so he
so he has a system to make sure that he
never loses it he does yes he's like
that willpower okay I've been looking up
like a person to help me like I need
like an add code well he has like a
system that somehow works because never
seen him lose one thing what is it I
don't know he knows to check like
numbers no he puts it in the same place
I don't know but the point is that when
I lose things he gets he gets so anxious
that he can't like when I'm like oh I
don't know know where my keys are it's
like he gets so upset with me and I'm
like I don't care about losing my keys
yeah you do every time I had to tell
them to just start the podcast without
me because every time I go to leave for
the podcast I can't find yes my water
but like there's 20 like the garage
opener is the one that makes me late the
most and it's hard to lose that it's so
I am bedazzling everything now
everything's bedazzled so yeah it's just
a sea of bedazzle but I'm like where's
the garage the garage I can't tell you
how many times I'm late because I'm
literally yeah my car's trapped in a
garage same it's just life I feel like
it's just my life
okay I want to get my tarot cards I
really think yeah yeah okay go get them
so see um no I can get them unless you
want to oh no I'm good but kalilah I'll
keep talking to you yeah yeah is this
really annoying to know believe
nothing's annoying okay so awesome I
want you to be on I want you to be our
fourth person if someone associate every
time if someone is an excellent kisser
right
like the best kisser you've ever you're
already saying no
you're already saying no hear me out
Annie
also Carlos what's the update on our
love affair are you off the hook I mean
I was found not guilty in bad friends
Court yeah but that's just because
um the prosecution didn't have good
evidence right right yeah but I mean I'm
still congrats
congrats to us yeah we got away with it
yeah all right we can text later we
fooled the world Carlos you and I
Against the World and he's shaking her
head I just I'm so disappointed in the
audience honestly
um they're just dumb it's like I love
you guys and I like want to believe the
best in you but the ones that don't get
it are like you're stupid and they're
the ones that are against us anyway I
guess they're just looking for reasons
to like wait so you're on hinge I only
turned it off for the girls no I don't
have hinge because I wanted I I'm not
ready that's why
I'm not ready for the boys and also I
kind of just like the idea of like
making out with a girl and like kind of
just having oh my God
is a Clinton
oh yeah that's okay last week they're
used I didn't know we didn't make out
but we had a great time cool yeah it was
really sweet I think she saw her stalker
though at the club it was kind of killed
yeah
oh my God wardrobe change
we like both outfits did you go what did
you fix your car out there did you
change the oil while you're out there
with my door that you're fun you are the
funnest you are a fun gal you are my
thing you're like me okay here we go
ladies wait what does it uh Taro sorry
I'm a little stuck in Taro just thinking
potatoes Boba yeah
um what do tarot cards predict the
future the pass through the present okay
so all of it tarot is non-predictive
because like I don't think we can ever
like know
what's going to happen in the future
yeah obviously so I think it's more like
for me it's like information about
what's going on in me now that I might
not see or um like you have a yeast
infection yeah exactly but I'm not
[ __ ] kidding you once so I didn't
know someone and I they got like a card
that sometimes represents fertility and
They begged me to do a reading and I
didn't want to because I don't like to
do that and they got like sheet white
and then the guy that did know her
called me and was like they had found
out they were pregnant an hour before oh
wow so like it's like it'll tell you
what's going on now and little you know
it was real awkward I had to leave
okay I'm really are you ready I'm on
board Okay cool so take the cards okay
I love that scoot's answer to add is
that he just puts things into place it's
like [ __ ] you so you overcame 80d he
didn't oh he didn't overcome it just no
see your mic your mic oh he didn't
overcome it no oh he just uh you're so
good at taking directions look like a um
vibrator bag it does it's not it's for
Tara
Shuffle it up and like think about your
life in general okay
okay however you want and then like
whenever you're ready tap it with your
left hand everyone's gonna be like this
is not how you feel terrible I know
they're gonna be like I used to like
this podcast yeah exactly this is just
how I do trash picks you guys saw you
trash Piggies can we change our name to
trash pigs I like trash pigs
I can look so much like a pig
I love trash bags you even need to yeah
it's already turned out the Lord was
already doing it we've seen your parents
okay here we go so I put I just tap yeah
whatever and then pass them back to me
hi okay and then we'll just go
really curious 82 is a gift
no physically I'm comfortable too
mentally unable to tell me my insides
I'm really I'm really curious that's a
[ __ ] raw rotten they've been [ __ ]
scooped out if you know what I mean
they've been okay screwed it out by a
one Mr Herrera
she's been getting banged bang banged
out okay so you got
um
okay so you got the Five of Swords okay
swords are a suit of like our mind and
anxiety [ __ ]
I'm your man at this okay fives are like
a suit of our minds and anxiety
um and our fears okay and you got the
five and then you got
um the four of cups this is my favorite
card because I think it's so funny and
then this one is um the Six of Pentacles
so
ready okay okay
hold on I need to look up one thing Oh I
thought you were just like showing us
you read she was like oh so I brought a
book and what if I was like okay that's
it
um no okay Five of Swords Five of Swords
so swords remember it's like all in your
head okay so it's not reality it's just
kind of what your mind is telling you
and what it is is that it's like
winning something
but it's not necessarily like
you don't need to hold on a second
um okay if the Five of Swords this is my
friend's book if the Five of Swords
that's come to you you're probably
considering a full-on Joan Crawford
don't [ __ ] with me display of your
strength and power
and guess what it will almost certainly
work you'll get what you want in the
short term but only because you have not
given up enough thought to the long term
how will this situation persist in spite
of your small victory
um will your showy performance make your
opponent double down in a way you can't
compete with well there will there be
Fallout and from an unforeseen quarter
who will okay
um
you are are you either already or
embroiled in a messy conflict or are on
the edge of tearing something down a
both baby do you feel like this is real
for you I really I do but the showy
thing is if if if I
I always want to win okay but I like to
quietly win okay so I think that the
showy part is maybe cautioning me too if
you're gonna do this
yeah make your take your victories
quietly yes and also like
um
if you feel like someone needs their
comeuppance they'll get it you don't
have to force it thank you and then also
not only that before a couple calls I
had one
okay well they're coming up when I
needed it
um but okay this is my favorite one
because I get it all the time and it's
so funny thank you for the comeuppance
thing because sometimes I want to go
full retaliatory don't and I'm just like
even in therapy I'm like I have Revenge
fantasies and in therapy she's like
kalila all the years that I've known you
like that is going to like eat at your
soul just leave them as fantasies and
also it just doesn't matter things
always work themselves out yeah in my
head I'm like oh I could destroy let me
destroy them totally and I used to think
that way too and then I realized like I
think only recently of like oh like
they'll get it eventually who cares I
don't want to put that out there you
know what I mean I'll do like no contact
almost with people I do yeah if I feel
like a conflict I just complete
I don't want to ever talk to people when
I'm like feeling like a victim of them
or mad at them or there's any poison in
me about them so sometimes I never talk
to them yeah I know there's a lot of
people and they can just kind of figure
out why I'm not wait but that's exactly
and no like the opposite of love is not
hate it's indifference yeah so if you're
actively hating somebody you are still
actively obsessed with loving them in
some way I remember when uh Troy my
ex-boyfriend first broke up with me and
I was like heartbroken and I was in
therapy and my therapist was like I was
like but I need to talk to him and I
need to figure out a bunch she was like
no like you really don't because it
doesn't matter how he's processing it
yeah and I will save my life by the way
she did yeah she's your therapist too
then yeah is it Esther
it's Esther it's Hester yeah she's
amazing
um truly like a lifesaver yeah for real
is she Whitney's too I feel like
everyone has the same one she's Bobby's
I've suggested her to a lot of people
you want her yeah
I'm just kidding any life life changing
no really like she is the most
incredible woman in the whole world in
the whole world I've ever gone to I
gotta take this out because she's I
don't know why she doesn't want me to
talk about it publicly but
all the the body worker no I need that
oh [ __ ] that I need I need an exorcism I
need my my hips released
bananas
oh [ __ ] I need to tell you about your
other cards the most adorable take on
add that I've ever heard in my life
which is well you look this up for when
she's done which is um uh gabar mate
on Joe Rogan on Rogan and we can watch
it it's like so precious what he says
about 80d is so cute I love that man
there's also a series of him where it's
like an eight part series about trauma
and he has one is Sarah Perell he is I
love his voice I love everything
send me that because I really really
good he also says this one thing which
really like hit me very hard he's like
no two kids have the same parent it's
like even if you're twins you don't have
the same parents like it's it's and that
gave me so much relief it when it comes
to like because then you're compatible
you're not you're not like competing
right with the like who your parents are
when they show up for you at a certain
time is completely different like their
financial situation how how you were or
even how you were in utero with your
even if it's a twin like every like you
do not have the same parent oh my gosh
yeah everything's completely different
for like like as in because of so like
my brother and my
they parent us so differently it's wild
yeah anyways okay I can't talk about
Okay so
let me just finish your reading yeah
this is my favorite card because it's
this person who has four cups and three
on the ground that are full and then
someone's even handing one down from
heaven and they're like this
yeah
yeah so it's like um
gratitude like it's calling for you to
see what you do have I need that okay
yeah yeah I just think it's so funny
that they're they're home full
yeah and then even if it feels like
there isn't much there's something you
know what I mean right right and and
like yeah and then the Six of Pentacles
is wow is that trippy unless Okay so
it's basically this rich person like
giving to other people look there's like
Beggars and then the person with the
money okay so am I the beggar well
that's the question because you could be
either
um and so
okay for those of you who had do you
want to do Beggars or richers first
um either or yeah okay so if you
identify as the Richie Rich take care
that you're not living above your means
the images plastered all over the media
of the extremely wealthy and the way
they use the world itself as their
playground can provoke jealousy longing
and compulsion it's perfectly
understandable to yearn for nice things
or a better standard of living but make
sure you are going about your
Acquisitions honestly not feeding a
shopping habit or mixing out a credit
card you'll have to deal with down the
line me I do that I that's my that's my
you are very like you'd never spend
money
but you I do on what products my family
I spent so yes but but it's like all of
the things combined why this is so
interesting no it's my my mom has
literally told me to like stop like you
need to cut everyone off because I don't
know how to say no to people needing
imagine they're men that are you're
making out with oh my God she has the
problem saying no to people the way we
do to peanuts yeah oh I love making out
I love making like oh the fun is thank
you
foreign
yeah me neither me neither someone who
identifies as the Beggars I feel you
maybe you're legitimately broke you're a
freelance and in and your income depends
on scoring jobs having clients who are
willing to pay you swiftly
as the head of a non-profit I was always
begging for money in the form of Grants
which often required I don't like when I
have to okay
sorry
it's asking whether there's anything you
can do to get out from under your
dependence on other people's money maybe
you're living off a wealthy parent but
their control over your life feels
bitter there's gonna be a whole clip on
the go island with this one you want me
to keep reading there's one thing that
pissed me off when people when people
were like commenting on me and Bobby's
breakup and they were like oh yeah there
goes back to coach she goes back to like
what coach like economy
they don't know that Bobby has like I've
always flown coach oh it's Bobby who's
going first class and me stay yeah in
the [ __ ] back dude my parents flew
first and put me in my brother and Coach
that's great what did they put your
brother in first and you and Coach yeah
they were like it's our money not yours
[ __ ] but but this one I don't have to
keep reading because this isn't you
um I don't know maybe bits and pieces
but like not quite but the Gratitude and
the first one definitely but maybe also
you're giving being a little you're
being Richie Rich with your family and
you need to chill I think I am because
my mom's like for the love of God like
so you can say no you can yeah and you
need to
yeah I
I give thousands of dollars to like dogs
yeah no and me and Aunt [ __ ] [ __ ]
for giving away our dog me and Annie
give thousands of dollars to clothes and
purses purses parents too I you have
[ __ ] Rich parents though lucky I am I
love spoiling my parents it's fun though
what do you get them first class tickets
I flew them out I pay for their meals
and stuff it's so fun I you know like
basic stuff you know yeah yeah but like
nice but that the basic stuff is the
best like I love
singing coach is the worst
and it's like if you if you can sit in
business or first I'm like do it oh
except except yesterday
with my own money I did fly back
um first class proud of you thank you
try to splurge I was like just kalila
just you need to sleep yeah it's an
overnight flight what would Annie do
make sure life better yeah so yes it's
about when we get off the plane except
why was there a dying man with two
flight nurses right behind me and I
could not sleep because all I could hear
was this dying agonal breathing behind
me wait and I was like it's exactly like
that and there were many times where I
was like is he croaking like right here
why does everyone think they can fly in
this state like people have been dying
on my planes like everybody
no but seriously I'm like don't fly if
you're like that I think maybe they
wanted the girl that was sitting next to
Princess Leia what what do you mean no
my God oh my God so sad but see here's
not the saddest wow that I forgot her
name Carrie Fisher everything Carrie
Fisher did you see that doc so good I
haven't haven't but I will but there was
a dying man behind me and I was like
here I was thinking I was I splurged on
myself and I could not enjoy a single
moment of that you should have gone back
you should have been like can I sit and
Coach I thought about that I was like
can I just move me back there to like a
whole empty row but then it was like you
know they try to be nice to you they're
like here what would you like for your
five course meal and I didn't want to
eat yeah I could hear the gurgling ew I
just was like I'm sad right now I'm like
depressed like I want to be there for
this what a pendant I couldn't separate
but also and he was like like right
behind me
are you not codependent anymore
is that what you're trying to say I'm
working on it we can feel out of that
working on it yeah but wait because I
will work on it I okay I was on I've
paid first class wait one second you
would have been able to sleep with a man
dying behind you look it really depends
on the it depends
well [ __ ] kaliva told me about this
girl that we know I think I told this on
this podcast before I'm in a [ __ ]
Ayahuasca trip okay you're not supposed
to have your phone on [ __ ] oh yeah
there's like it's like did I tell this
to you no I did turn it on the podcast I
think yes and I I turned my phone on
like prematurely I thought I was done
tripping was not she's like so and so
just do three people found dead one in a
coma I'm like I had to go because the
girl I had to go hey girl I wish you
well but I cannot
did you did you get it out of your head
I got her out of my head but I had
something like eating at me at in yoga
today and I was like get out [ __ ] get
I'm thinking about this other person if
somebody says they have a stomach ache
in my vicinity I have so much anxiety I
have to like
meditate or take a Klonopin or something
but it's like we have the same to effort
yeah but it's because I've I'm worried
about throwing up myself like I don't
get grossed out by it it's like I have
too much empathy pain yeah like I'll get
a stomach ache and I'm not trying to
brag it's not like I don't brag I'm so
nice no it's not it's not nice actually
it's a it's like not nice yeah it's like
actually unfair to people it's selfish
yeah because it's not letting them have
their experience yeah but I would have
just let that guy die no um
I was on the plane it was a red eye
Todd and I were separated okay the worst
which they just we got the tickets too
late no I wouldn't would agree nobody
would agree and it's you know what no
I'm okay with it in first and yeah
except this one lady
we were sitting behind each other and um
a a and I understand if you don't want
to switch aisle if you don't want to
switch aisle to window I'm totally fine
yeah that makes sense people really like
aisles in first class and I support that
but so if you don't want to switch
that's totally fine we were both window
there was a woman
she was a nightmare sitting next to Todd
they had an open seat and they were like
we're gonna call someone up but before
we bring him up why don't you move up
there because they did there was a
person in coach they didn't have a
preference of whether they got
um aisle or window
do you want to just move up to this
aisle in front of you so she can sit
there and she goes no why she's a sort
of the [ __ ] that's right no reason
there was no reason she was I'm settled
in and then it's fine like all right be
a [ __ ] it's fine it's your right to be
a [ __ ] she then kept talking to us and
she kept going oh the dog's whining
because his mother's not next to him he
wants to I kept going shoot the dog
likes us together he's completely quiet
when I'm sitting there well she's trying
to make sure that like you weren't mad
at her maybe you missed an opportunity
to set the tone up front what I do is if
I separated from somebody and I know
that I want the person to move and offer
it to me I'll be extra loud talking to
my sister like hey do you have my thing
and then they just get so annoyed by
them
I'm surprised you didn't employ that
strategy the [ __ ] was that lazy I
really don't like it when people don't
do something nice for no reason yeah
it's like guys yeah sometimes I
appreciate it though I'm like you know
what all right I think of all the times
I [ __ ] dismay didn't want to do it'd
be nice and then I'm like oh look at you
you just didn't do that I know I'm kind
like I wish I was like that yeah I don't
like it yeah because you don't like I
don't like people who aren't like that
yeah like who are not generous or yeah
generous what happened oh this one woman
on a plane like um oh I pee all the time
on a plane and also like I have to pee
all the time and also I spill something
every time without fail yeah you're the
best every my dad said like every ever
since I was little it'd be like okay
she's failed again like one time at
least and I was next to this woman who
was obviously you know like the opposite
of she was like yeah you know like sat
up the whole plane her like leg wasn't
like above her head like ours anyways
and she's like um she's like I want I
need the aisle but if you do have to go
to the bathroom let me know because I
don't want you stepping over me okay and
I was like okay but that's my nightmare
like because I do like the Window Seat
but as a people pleaser yes I know when
they fall asleep it's like I will get a
UTI I'm like yes I'm literally like
holding my [ __ ] like but imagine she
specifically said and don't walk over me
and I'm a Spiller so I had the worst I
was so tense that whole flight I was
like
I and finally like at one point she was
sleeping and I had to pee but I held it
for like two hours because I was like I
can't wake her up she's terrifying she
had like five can I have 95s on she was
like right so she's clearly already in
her own suffering as well whatever it is
there was a woman on her way to the
Philippines I was sat next to Bobby the
woman onto his left was exactly that
type yeah and she said this she woke up
from her Slumber like mid-flight and
Bobby didn't really do anything he might
have accidentally like kicked his
backpack in front of him
and she got up she sprung up and she was
like you are moving around too loudly I
am trying to sleep and I'm like
headphones [ __ ] noise canceling yeah
you're on the word that person noise
cancel your [ __ ] life right but I and
but he you know we're both so spineless
so he was just awesome just say sorry
he's like oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
noise cancel cultural can't stop talking
about it but it's scary to be around
that type of person because especially I
like to pull my knees up I like to lean
I like to be I'm a sloppy fly yes yes
Comfort is everything I like to put my
socks on I like to expose my socks so I
don't even I'm not really into passenger
shaming me neither are you me neither
and it's like a baby's crying it's like
it sucks but also it's just a plane like
what are you gonna do yeah but I had
okay I had I had two
separate parties in first class both
drunk oh oh sorry so loud parties I was
like okay
they were screaming during a red eye
screaming and it was like I am really
working on like surrendering in my life
and not being like
like I am like attached to the idea that
I'm gonna like have a peaceful red eye
right and I'm attached to that idea but
I don't necessarily get that idea I'm
not entitled to that that's just an idea
of what I thought was gonna happen and
I'm working on just like you just get
what you get it's just how it goes and
you just make the best of it or whatever
it's really hard and I'm such a loudy
that I have to kind of like support
other loudies because I've definitely
been that [ __ ] you know so I'm like all
right is it's too hypocritical of me to
be the one yelling but it was like it
was an insane amount of screaming it was
on a red eye aiming on a red eye it was
like but I felt like the flight
attendant should have done it it's like
that's your [ __ ] job you should have
gone over and been like listen first of
all you're cut off like like ground the
plane at this point these people are in
a black that's insane it was crazy how
does the flight attendant not say
something when the flight attendants are
always so rude to me like um ma'am your
toe is in the aisle it's like yeah I
know
before they run over yes and first class
that's what I literally am paying
thousands and thousands of dollars to
get them to let me put my toe in there
I'm low hanging fruit I like I've had
like my we saw what you did a mustache
yeah get your toe out of the aisle I'm
pretty sure I've had several like broken
foot bones because carts have just been
rolled over my foot on the out like they
don't even tell me they're just like
gonna run over this [ __ ] remember did
you did I tell you I broke my toe so see
you wouldn't shut up about your broken
door if she's on the right seat isn't
she yes that's a broken toe seat why
because I mean Esther had the most
it was like the Earth shook when Esther
Burger tell well I tripped from standing
that's it and I thought it was from
surfing sorry no uh second time so I
didn't tell you about this one I swear I
was walking
back somewhere I shouldn't like give
details but anyways someone who's a
parent at the school and I always feel
kind of awkward because I'm like not
there you know like biological mom but
I'm still like well anyways
so they were like hi Sophie and I turned
around to say hi and I was wearing those
do you know those squishy shoes like the
sandals that everyone's wearing they're
comfy now yeah you know what I'm talking
I think they're like yeah so they have
no support so I turned around I was like
hi and then I tripped up and caught the
full weight of my full body weight on my
big toe that one and basically just like
maimed my toe like it was gone
it was not the same toes no I'm just
remembering a thing and I'm wondering if
I want to share it with you guys go on
wait wait a second if you you this is
something else it's a different tone yes
and the guy was like and it started
gushing blood and the guy was like are
you okay and I was like and and he's
like you have to like play it off
because you're out of school you're yeah
you're not the mom exactly like I'm not
gonna be like oh my God my toe like
there's a four-year-old he was like no
but seriously so see like it's it's
really bleeding and I was like I know
talk about it now because he's the yeah
I loved how you sent me like 18
different angles of your broken toe my
foot oh you're fat with my foot okay
tell the thingy thing I want I there's a
picture to accompany it I yesterday went
to Catalina Island for the first time oh
I've never been there my Mary Lou
Rodriguez my hypnotist is in town with
her boyfriend Scott she's the best
follower Mary Lou hypnotizes you on
Instagram but we went to Catalina we
went on the ferry we went over
uh out of Long Beach out of Long Beach
we went and saw the botanical gardens
where there's this giant like structure
for the guy whose name I forgot who used
to own the island and I thought it would
be funny if I did like a handstand Todd
was in a picture was taking a picture I
was like I'll do a handstand where it's
like I'm looking like he's like eating
my [ __ ] out in the picture you know oh
my God that's very Jenna of you yeah I
was about to say it just felt like funny
to be like sex position
and but I'm not like I kind of fake that
I'm gonna be like tough enough to do
that against this marble structure you
know like I've gained a few lbs it's I
don't know how much my wrist can hold I
haven't done yoga in a while so I am
pissing out I'm not really doing it and
then all of a sudden my my friend's
boyfriend who does not know that I'm
like full of [ __ ] when I say I'm gonna
do something like a cartwheel into my
with my vagina to my boyfriend's mouth
he just lifts my legs up and I'm like no
no no and my wrists are like whipping
I'm like no no no no I broke my neck
like I could have been in a [ __ ] like
coming in like
wait the rest of my life like I
explained like that what you were trying
to do I was trying to do like a
cartwheel what text me the pic yeah I
can do a cartwheel I was trying to do
like a like a round like a roundhouse
roundhouse and then my vagina would be
in his face you know you were just
trying to do that like after not doing
that's really hard it was too hard and
as I was going to do it I was like it's
very hard everything's marble this is
how I know I'm like deeply codependent
because
um when I first started doing yoga I
went to a class that was like way past
my um capabilities and it was a power
yoga class and I you know my handstands
are fair like I need a wall behind me
I'm not that great
um but I injured myself fully fully
fully fully because he was like kick
your legs up kick your legs come on I'm
right here and
um he wasn't right there and um oh my
God you poor thing and he was like Oh I
thought that you had it looked like you
had it
and I didn't have it so he was just like
saying that he was there but I'm right
here I got you I got manipulative and
rude and weird but that's the whole
[ __ ] thing but also hey I'm as
codependent because I literally wouldn't
say that it hurt in because I didn't
want to make them oh I that's true I was
like no I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine help somebody help oh yeah and fomo
go together too I think because it's
like right so I am having fomo
codependently because I've been looking
at this enough oh it was yeah we can
fill you in later but it was it purely
his mistake but I would not have ever
let him know that no of course not oh my
God I'm so sorry I embarrassed you I
know exactly like you look dumb and I
apologize I wonder if we could do a
handstand now and you caught my legs I
have uh oh wait if you did it yeah and
you know maybe we would fall into each
other's [ __ ] scissors yeah like Annie
imagine that our dream so handstand into
scissors oh I have to work on it
a.m Hot Yoga Today you did are you tired
uh not right now but did it rejuvenate
you it woke you up it did well I was
like I I want to go back to moto yoga
but Moto has different like level yeah
and I have to do just regular Moto I
can't do the Moto flow yet because I'm
yes I've done in a while and then I'll
be too look at this
um no wait wait wait close up on your
face I am God is dead to me dying Annie
that doesn't even look like you
ow are you okay I'm I'm healing
wow oh my God ow that looks so [ __ ]
looks like you're facing uh the movie
yeah exactly look at that 11 right by a
monster
um you know what you look like I mean I
couldn't look fatter but it's okay I'm
on I'm doing a I'm doing a challenge you
know what this looks like to me have you
guys ever heard of pleasure Doms look up
at my boyfriend's [ __ ] face he looks
like a pleasure Dom here like he's there
are types of men he does he's really
enjoying it let's do it Kyla wait the
scissors I'll be Annie you be Todd
but nobody was helping me down I'm like
guys so I had to just release
that's so unsafe you could have actually
broken your nose no I was very put
yourself with your neck there was
nothing else to do no one was helping me
Todd was laughing Todd was laughing and
the other guy didn't know I was he
thought I was kidding I'm a comedian
that's all he knows yeah when people
don't know that you're like no I'm not
okay
I I fell off my horse two days ago bat
like
flew through the air like Superman no
nothing like Superman I wish God yeah it
was fun I was fine comment away we know
did you apologize to the Horace I felt
terrible to for the horse because I was
like I know I rode you wrong that's why
it happened
I just said that to a boy before I know
I was like sorry I wrote you wrong man
guys I went to skank Fest I was supposed
to go last year but I had like a really
really bad crazy creepy stabby stalker
oh and I had to like I was like I'm busy
buying a gun I'm not able to go but they
were so respectful they were so amazing
everyone was [ __ ] incredible like I
love that every comic I was like crying
laughing but one of the comics
that I've really bonded with is this guy
I'm not going to say his name just
because I don't want to like out who I'm
talking about but um he hangs out with
some of my ex-boyfriends some of them a
crew of my ex-boyfriends and he made me
like kind of miss them and in a way
where it's not like I'm gonna hang out
with them again but it's making me like
forgive them and see the good in them
again which is very very helpful for my
yeah my forward movement but it was I
there were people that I met on this
[ __ ] weekend and people that I saw
that I haven't seen in like five years
it was I was on acid I was on where
where is everything it was in Vegas it
was so fun and then I got Vegas added
for New Year's so if you want to come
I'm doing nice I'm doing all four shows
New Year's Eve that sounds really fun
and the day before I'd be done I like
that my tits are so soft squishy let me
see squishy so squishy what do you mean
mine too did you lose weight
that's not squishy oh look at her
why did you point like this probably
mine because I lost weight so they have
they I have like sad like she was late
for the movie not on purpose
honestly I just was so stressed out hmm
do you get stressed about your well that
one it was like kind of stress that one
was particularly right were you are you
so happy with
how there was yeah I'm shocked you know
it was supposed to be on streaming it's
really good when did they decide that oh
we're gonna do a wider after they tested
it and people loved it but like that's
only happened with one other movie it's
your face the entire were you
self-conscious about your face the
entire movie they did a really good job
of shooting it though like with the
camera and stuff that no I wasn't
self-conscious but I thought it was just
gonna be on streaming come and go
nothing and I'm like what it's more just
like shocking than anything else are you
blowing up on social media and stuff
and I've gotten more followers but like
not crazy
not blowing up at all um nobody cares no
okay so you got Justice page of
Pentacles and the Five of Swords
hold on Talk Amongst yourselves let me
just get it wait the Five of Swords is
also what I got yeah no you got the
you want to know why we're getting it
it's because it's about the same [ __ ]
thing yeah probably I'm excited to hear
what it is okay Justice
call it right now I mean don't call her
we won't tell her she's a [ __ ] okay
um generally it means that an ethical or
moral issue has come into your sphere
and you're having to deal with it maybe
you are directly involved you've been
wrong wronged or someone feels you've
done them wrong maybe you've witnessed
an injustice and it's giving you
feelings whatever side of the conflict
you're on the Justice card beseeches you
to act fairly Now isn't the time for
vengeance or martyrdom is not the time
for gossip or defensiveness the Justice
card asks us to sit with ourselves and
meditate on the issue at hand how we did
or did not play into it how we might
have handled it differently how we will
conduct ourselves in the future
please keep going I love it no I love it
it's good because I do I keep trying to
try to defend myself it doesn't work
yeah Justice is asking you to work yeah
just don't do anything it just doesn't
matter I know what other yeah about
myself exactly and what other people
think it actually doesn't matter yeah it
really doesn't but I I don't practice
what I all of the assets I did at skank
Fest really made me feel so
like like literally the episode I did
with Greg Fitzsimmons on my podcast on
my solo podcast anyone
um Greg your first guest he's my first
comedian guest here I love it I know
he's my favorite we want him on here
he's one of my best friends I love him
but we but I
um
I just was like so self-conscious and I
just realized like that's such like a
weight not only is it wasted for me but
it's wasted for like the message I'm
trying to like share with the world and
I think what I like where I am able to
help people is to like show them that
I'm not self-conscious you know that I
am like busting through I think it's
also like helpful to show people like
that you are yeah yeah yeah also to just
accept that your emotions can be influx
at all times that it's like you can have
strong days like certainly like my
hormones are always shifting every day
there are days of the month where I'm
just I feel completely invincible and
others where I'm like oh my God like a
light Breeze could take me down today
it's just like also women we just are
like predisposed to be perfectionists
because that's because that's like what
it is expected of us it's so unfair and
like I think the one difference I have
seen since smile came out is that I'm
like
I'm being see like I'm out there so much
more and so I'm so terrified of like
scrutiny you know what I mean saying
something wrong or doing something wrong
you know like the more you're out there
the more scarier it is but it's like for
me I'm trying to do the opposite where
it's like care less the more I'm out
there because yeah because we are going
to get more yes like the more successful
we get and like the more like I ain't
going away my numbers ain't going down
yeah everything's going up so it's like
more people are gonna be witness to us
and they're gonna have the so the
percentage you know small of people that
don't like us it that does just get
bigger because it totally yeah you're
gonna have ten bags on you yes you want
to take them off and when it comes like
just people like existing on the
internet in a very like negative way
there is this one Tech talk her name is
teffy I love her she's incredible but
she said something I don't know if it
was her quote or somebody else's but
it's like the psychology behind why
someone would like project that much
like hate on the Internet is because
nothing is she says nothing is worse
than not having a witness to your
existence people want to be seen and
heard so it's like rather than not be
seen at all they exist in this way
saying the worst most horrible hurtful
things because they'd rather be seen in
that way than not have a witness to
their existence that is so sad which is
true but also but also
maybe they have this true opinion about
one of us but no but they don't know us
so they're tripping in but it's like
you're entitled to your like everyone
every the world's entitled to be
whatever it is around me you know it's
like it really is up to me to just not
take it off exactly but that but also to
have compassion and understand that
those mean comments come from a deep
place of hurt in them kind of because
there's a difference between having an
opinion about somebody and having that
discourse and then straight up just yeah
being like yeah like ew she's so ugly
yeah right so that's what I'm working
right where it's like you [ __ ] pig
trash gold digging this it's like that
is like oh you just want to be seen and
held again my parents do you know that
they do not read comments and they do
not read reviews not one and I swear
they actually practice it they do not
look at them that's awesome that is not
at all and whenever I say I am they're
like why are you doing that yeah how did
they come to figure that probably read
enough bad ones so they were like [ __ ]
that no but it's just it made them
happier as people but also it's like
they're gonna keep doing what you're
doing you're gonna keep doing what
you're doing you're going to keep doing
it doesn't really matter yeah but also
like if you think about like the lens
you're looking at things like if I'm if
I use skank fest last year like I could
not go to skank fest last year I was in
so much fear of
like fans being near me having access to
me like I the I was working in a
vibration and I'm not saying I was wrong
I I was [ __ ] terrified the [ __ ] that
I was getting like and um that's why I
turned my DMs off like nobody has access
to me like that now
um and you know I have like names that
people need to know I mean I'm PR you're
not supposed to talk about stuff but I
think it's real and it's important but
so if I had gone to skank Fest like last
year I would have been so scared when
everyone has to take pictures for me
stuff like that this year I came in like
the vibrational feeling safe feeling
loved all that I had so much fun meeting
everyone it was so cool you know but
it's the same experience it's just my
lenses you know different yeah
yeah yeah and I hope to God you never
take that purse off your body in fact I
hope you shower yeah no it's like I
literally I was showing her I have like
I want it to become you also Annie I
feel like I definitely even from
listening to the podcast which this
sounds stalkery but I listen to everyone
we love it but I can I can totally see
like so much like where you're thinking
about a lot like growth in the way
you're thinking about things even for
like just you and you talk about it
which is nice because people have to
understand that like they can change all
that they don't have to live in whatever
and also I I like kind of brag I think
it's funny to brag like it's funny to be
like this but also it's like because I
have trouble like to get to like a
bigger place for myself to get to like
to break some of my limiting beliefs I
have to like imagine I'm someone else
exactly because I can't it's not in my
realm so I am like be like me [ __ ]
like if you're feeling broke and like
shitty get [ __ ] start bragging and [ __ ]
and like be like me like be like me I
know people say I want you to be able to
get funky yes and I'm like hey wait hold
on a second I hate myself so much that I
have to like say that I'm good it to
believe it then the hate yourself goes
away yes exactly self-love no no I'm
saying it goes away but I'm not being
cocky it started from a place of yeah
pulling yourself overboard yeah
overcompensating yeah exactly cocky who
calls you cocky you're like the least
sometimes
were like I was like oh God don't you
know from the spot and she goes only
then number one Wednesday
oh that's kind of like a joke no it's
perfect no but it is also a joke
yeah bragging is a joke it's great brag
name drop
wait sorry Talk Amongst yourselves okay
you have page of Pentacles too hold on
Talk Amongst yourself that's the title
of this Talk Amongst yourself okay sorry
I know I'll read it to you
um
okay so Court cards can be you a
situation or someone else so Pages
represent youth um newness and learning
students of the tarot hold on
um
you're learning the ways of the material
world what's your sign again cancer
cancer so your water but this is an
earth sign Earth sign card which is good
for us water people it brings us down
your water too yeah Pisces oh fun yeah
my dad's a cancer oh is Scorpio a water
sign I don't know Sky reminders
no no I mean maybe in that you're from
Philly and like are funny oh my God he
is funny he's so funny okay
um you're almost there Annie okay if
it's a person another person you can
depend on them there's something that
raises a bit of skepticism about them
their youth their lack of experience or
their very sheltered life regardless of
that their wish to apply themselves and
make up for these deficits is real
that's if it's a person
than if you are
stop daydreaming and start doing perhaps
you've always wanted to learn a certain
trait or take up an interesting hobby or
figure out a way to monetize a hobby or
draw some numerical Perfection milk in
those drawings for a while huh guys yeah
it's like do it you have to take the
crucial First Steps it's all very like
material like it's doing not like
feeling and imagining and then if it's a
situation it's a good opportunity and
it's at the you're very much at the
beginning if you want me to read on
about any of those I will no it's okay
okay see weren't we supposed to get
matching tattoos that said honey hole
yeah honey hole oh my God yeah I'll do
them anytime anytime I just got these
ones honey what was that from the last
podcast we did no it's because scoot
apparently says honey hole okay I say
honey hole honey hole is a place in a
lake where you fish where like there's a
lot of fish they don't let me know there
because I talk so much yeah right
exactly exactly
five fishing they're like I honey the
poo that are Winnie the Pooh that honey
hole but I always say that like hunting
in like Texas phrases are all vaguely
like homoerotic and sexual so like like
where's your honey hole term where
should we get it where should we put it
on our [ __ ] just kidding but the O
is our [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just for a little Annie you don't have
any um tattoos
no tattoo I just realized that is that
cool to not have any time yeah we'll be
your first one
just got them from this guy that just
moved here from New York they're like
Mexico no I like I like the one on the
right arm I was gonna ask if that was
new because it looks pretty fresh it's a
naked weighty guys if you have a
thousand dollars to spend these are the
lip kits for you what is that Lisa Rinna
yeah oh good but they're so [ __ ] put
them on backwards can I oh it's like a
little kid putting their shoes on the
wrong foot can I try it or do I owe you
200 if I try no you could try it but
there it comes with like the lipstick I
always end up losing them but they're so
[ __ ] expensive but they're so good
wait are they really a thousand dollars
no they're like 50 I think oh my God I
thought you were seriously is so much is
this right I never know I'm not right
there's so many I didn't realize how
many ways you could do it wrong I did
this last 13 reasons why she can't put
the ears on how many nepo babies does it
take to put on an ear that's so cool
what to play a high schooler when you
were how old were you 22. that was the
worst yeah uh 26th was like
okay wait someone tell me how to put
these I don't know either I'm waiting
for Annie this Annie here on the one
closest to me like this
yeah oh it's cute and do that it really
is so cute it's a good look for us yeah
oh my God this is right and oh and it's
gonna go through this thing yeah the
long ones might be hard to get in there
my stylist I showed him our last trash
Tuesday and he was like
oh why didn't you wear makeup you look
like [ __ ]
in the last one I was like wow I thought
you look so cute I don't think my ears
support these remember last time they
kept falling off I think it's called
Buxom are you guys ready yeah
very corpse very decaying corpse colored
on you my
mouth is so big when I put lipstick on
you know what I love about your wrists
oh that's a cute thing to say what
they're chubby
um
it's it's a very like you did it again
flatulence
um they look like um they remind me of
like my Filipino
um aunties in what ways have like just
gold bangles on them and it's very
nostalgic for me but I was gonna say
about um flatulence yes
macro flatulence I guess like men and
women the fart science between men and
women differ and women my cards I have
Micro flatulence so we let it out slowly
over the day and men have a more like
thunderous that's because they're
allowed to they're allowed to yeah you
think it's because they're allowed to
and we just kind of like yes
made a squeaker [ __ ] then evolve I
push them out I'm masculine I push mine
out you do oh yeah I force but then
don't you think that because of like
we've had to stay ladies for so long
we've evolved to then have Micro
flatulence oh maybe so yeah that makes
sense like I've never heard a girl fart
audibly why but guys everyone oh really
I heard you do it like five times no I
feel like with girls it's like silent
air can I do anything funny and maybe
we'll cut it out but I don't know that I
was at I'm going to the Chanel party
tonight and Chanel dressed me and Scoot
and I went to the Chanel headquarters
which is like white carpets and like
it's so fancy period on it we're both
yeah but like no but I didn't but we're
both so like dirty yeah you know what I
mean and they were like uh and and so
anyways I'm trying stuff on and like as
I'm leaving the woman goes
um possibly a um Epsom salt bath
tomorrow and I'm like why and she's like
helps with the puffiness oh no
can you believe that
where did you think where did you think
you were puffy I don't know but I'm just
saying it's so funny like hold on I know
fashion people are brutal brutal they're
so mean but they're being like they're
honest like with their eye I want to see
your lips wait put it on you want can
you put it on yeah you have such
luscious yeah see how I've already lost
one of the pieces that's another thing I
have to like not defend for like you're
getting too much work done I'm like I'm
getting nothing done you don't have
forth any work you know it's funny I I I
feel the same you know what pisses me
off the most it's gonna look cute on you
yeah because when people think I have
cheap fillers and I'm like I know
because yeah
no you know what everyone wants to look
like you but they're getting what
they're getting of cheek fillers yeah
that's what it is it's like I will tell
you what I've had but like the cheeks
are not it like I've had the most and
it's been an insecurity of mine my whole
life and now
you know so that that kind of they're
jealous
there is this guy that I might like I
don't usually like crush on people
um that I don't know but I feel like I
would this is how I want to transition
into back into being single there's this
guy
who his entire personality is being a
pleasure Dom and apparently all he does
is just make you come over and over and
over and over again like that you you
don't service him in any way he just
fully Services you they're pleasure Doms
and do you pay them I used to have a guy
ahead of my phone named mouth
mouth
that's him yeah that's yeah
I don't know what he did not care if I
made him come at all he just was like
wow
I just want to imagine his name he's my
friend now but I have to tell you this
is him right just you don't have to play
the audio because I might come but it's
about nice slugs I have legs I like
totally didn't put two and two together
that you
are single and I have so many of scoots
old man friends I do like oh they're not
old they're just awesome
yeah what were they pleasure Doms
because that's my that's it's for sure
older guys are more pleasurey dummy than
young they've got to do it really fast
yeah and also no be young no no they're
good boys now no I'm not saying oh yours
yours is wonderful you just cracked your
neck in such a
no okay this is so excited
I have so many ideas okay so we um
scoots old pleasure dog is he friends
with brown he's he actually yeah but
strike me as a pleasure Dom do you what
do you think about people being divorced
and having kids
um if he's a pleasure dog yeah
they have to be rich because kalila will
end up paying for their kids to go to
college yeah exactly like they have to
be completely like fully no I hear that
do you know what I mean I can't pay with
this I uh regular blue collar I'm rich
and divorced you know what I thought
about this this is gonna I thought about
it I thought about this I was just like
and no I'm just like putting my name in
the put yeah putting your hats put your
bald head in the Hat that's like
put your head there's some major perks
of dating someone with kids you know
what kind of dad they're gonna be don't
have to just guess yes maybe uh that it
it maybe it will fulfill my um desire to
sorta want have kids you know like where
I'm I'm in limbo oh like half half like
a half and half out
um you look so hot yeah you look so and
the lipstick because you're ahead looks
big like honestly like your body looks
so little and your head looks so big you
look like a [ __ ] movie star I'm
literally like seeing stars in my eyes
right now it's so because I wanted to
make fun of the hat and now it's like
with the lipstick no I know it's hot
Carlos Annie's coming in for like this
girl crazy when I walked in today
yes I thought to myself you look very
very hot today thank you and I think
like you kind of have like your hair a
little bit behind her ears yes you guys
I was singing this yeah
fabulous fabulous fabulous thank you and
so do we Annie look at my ears oh they
are desperate we're like someone look at
us nothing we look I look like so like
okay show me this pleasure Dom yeah I
want to hear him I'm gonna listen
you can come clylla it's free country
you can come whenever women need to come
more your Dom is somebody that um makes
their entire job
um making somebody finish and it's like
finish a lot and hard and over and yeah
there's scenes I have where you know we
hit like 25 in the course of wow that
sounds tiring pleasure Dom
no I do like I do like porn where the
guy just makes the girl James didn't got
canceled right he did yeah but he used
to like [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of those
porn stars like beyond their acting
where it was like they're not acting and
they're like in pain they're coming so
much right right and that sounds like it
would be like we see more pictures of
him
um he 25 is a lot it's so much yeah like
I feel like it would make your like [ __ ]
like broken yeah I think we'll never get
at work it's like yeah it gets too much
like sometimes yeah that is him yeah
but he's a porn star he is yeah no but I
think I like that he is kind of like
soft-spoken he's so cute
that's crazy it's great I have a pool of
men for you I have none would they like
me
no they would hate you of course they
would like you they like me because I
know what a honey hole is the question
is is that like would you like them but
I think you would because I love all of
them they have such wondrous
personalities and like uh oh that sounds
ugly no but
no that sounds like the ugliest man I've
ever no no no none of them are ugly
they're all hot but they're just also
like cool not just hot no you have to
date the Yanni guy that guy yes they
would like you
um oh my friend Nick thinks you're hot
too but I think you just got a
girlfriend but I think everybody thinks
he's an island boy they already have one
Nick
oh Nick by the way Nick where is our
jewelry where is our jewelry Nick
honestly thank you so much for the chips
you gave me the best he brought me crab
leg trip better than um Kelly Clarkson's
chips these actually I'm not gonna lie
neck are the best it's neck and neck
folks and I do want to tell you really
quick I was at an escape room coffee
shop yes they both went together got a
free cup of coffee with the escape room
it's like to make you escape for each
other then you'd have diarrhea you have
to get out faster you go so many places
so listen so listen I'm in there and
Kelly Clarkson like full Annie Letterman
style bust in the door I'm in line she
goes get the caramel frappuccino it's
the best thing like screaming in my face
just a totally not acting like she's
[ __ ] Kelly Clarkson just being insane
and then I'm like okay I'll get with
Kelly Clarkson then she was gone it's
beautiful that is a beautiful story wait
a second is your Nick the guy who also
spearfishes yes oh he is hot and he's so
hot I made it over 14. but my neck like
gets like pelagic fish it matters what
size the fish they get yes yes because
my neck gets like the biggest like most
prized fish and he like fish stamps him
he creates art around it you're gonna
love Scoops so much it's wild oh wait
can I just tell you something my neck my
neck we're having bear fishes but he
also creates the backgrounds for every
music video you've ever liked he works
with Beyonce he works with he's what he
makes up for in fish size
yeah he has a big ass [ __ ] fish but
he also has a little bit I know listen
you can pretend like you don't like this
Hollywood [ __ ] but you are in it a
little bit I'm okay
this is a perfect example of what's hot
like he is in the industry but he is
rugged he knows he's like a man he's got
like a tattered he's got a tattered book
with him at all when I met him I I
thought he was faking like being like
that I literally was like no come on you
don't actually care about that if you
want to be famous and then like and then
I realized like no he actually cares way
more about like boring motorcycles and
stuff but then like you know is that why
you're wearing this outfit to impress
him
is this motorcycle
but Annie yeah I'm not Asian and you
cannot compete with happy my next from
the Virgin Islands why can't you just
date both for now
well one didn't give us jewelry yeah
what kind of jewelry does he have my
neck didn't he makes jewelry incredible
juice listen let's be real the reason
you're here to begin with is because
Carlisle is trying to get his jewelry me
and Nick stuck around no no this is I'm
speaking directly to Nick you I I think
Nick's afraid that if he gives us the
jewelry he's gone and I can't promise
that's not the thing can you send me
what's his Instagram oh you'd probably
like this stuff we will promote it we
want to wear it we want to be adorned in
your jewelry such a fan of your work
okay it's interesting I like a little
bit more of the simple stuff but I do
love it oh this is not good for you Nick
no stop like I love that yeah I just
like the I like more simple I love that
see I like like kind of like flashy yet
also simple if that makes any sense
oh my God look at that but also my neck
is yours it's a skull with teeth of
jewels no it's really good he's our Nick
and you know okay I'm obsessed and then
look at my neck
but then I'm famous
just kidding
um I got recognized on the island of
Catalina by the black guy
good right it's creepy cool look at mine
here's a picture of him where's your
neck I don't know I'm not so hot I love
him I just had such a why is Nick such a
hot name it's a hot boy name right
Nicholas is Nicholas come on Nicholas I
mean it's twice divorced which is like
gives him a little extra
um what does that give him like he's
like been through it well you guys thank
you so say thank you so much thank you
guys it's hard to end honestly I'll come
back anytime like whatever not like you
need our help because smile is the
number one you don't need it no but I I
love being here yeah Maya Wes we love
you we love you guys we love you guys
can't oh God Wes right now competing CT
I wish I could just call him CPT is not
like in our orbit like TT I feel like is
like I'm too good for you girls yeah way
too hot for me I need I here's the thing
oh yeah one more thing don't you feel
like his feet smell in a way that's
gross CT I'm sure you stinky boys I like
a little bit of stinky boy but foot
smell to me is not the one not the
answer not foot not a good one um I will
say this OC they cannot be too
attractive I'm not really into I mean
it's not pretty a tint
yeah trust me I know not pretty for you
I know not pretty I know that yeah thank
you I'm on it that's so insulting to
Nick Joel her neck but no neck Nick
knows he's hot no Nick is hot I don't
like pretty neck you're hot but
the jewelry the jewelry he was like I
thought it'd be too weird to bring it to
him like Nick it's so weird you didn't
bring it he brought such good presents
it's like just throw a [ __ ] dime or
throw a little jeweled thing inside the
[ __ ] chips I'm like the person that
packs up before class is over wait girl
can I tell you the best thing wait I
have one Nick flashback when we brought
him to our eyes they're never gonna love
you we brought him to our Island and
then
and then uh we were going to go to a
strip club and then it never happened
and then he missed his flight and he
goes
well I was like why are you staying here
and Clyde's like get why why didn't you
get your fighting because you told me to
meet you at that so he said because you
guys told me to stay and we're like Nick
Jess
no no no no do a bunch of add kids we
make plans we never follow I know
there's one thing about Sophie we're
never gonna let you leave but you unpack
your suitcase immediately when you
arrive yeah or else I can't poop
I won't poop till I've unpacked my
suitcase at a hotel oh I dump mine
upside down throw everything everywhere
and then I go pee and I don't flush it
to assert the abdominance over myself to
a certain dominance over my room
likes tape men that's what I like wait
oh I have a question sorry what is the
toad towards you what is a chode what do
you think a child is it's like a short
fat to you little Runway okay so two
people 44 and maybe 43 and older it's a
teen yep oh craziest [ __ ] realization
uh it's the same I know but like no to
them same I was like it's obviously
something a dick that's as long as it is
wide and they were like what
I was like okay these other language
hasn't evolved these are the vendors
setting her up yeah I get excited don't
even know what a chode is bring me the
Zodi get it choted all right this was so
fun this was amazing thank you guys love
you guys guys see you next week
[Music]
thank you
[Music]